Speaker 1: Lauren Boebert. Radical Republican
Congresswoman Lauren Boebert has shifted from the
relentless attacks on electric vehicles
to attempts to limit access to certain
types of firearms. Now, there's a lot of
this sky is falling stuff from the right
on electric vehicles. We heard yesterday from
Marjorie Taylor GREENE if everybody gets an
electric vehicle, it's going to be a dystopia and
there's not going to be any power. There's going
to be blackouts. People will die. There will be no
food. It'll be crazy. And we debunked that piece
by piece yesterday. Lauren Boebert, her sort of
comrade in arms, as we might call it, even though
I don't know that they really like each other that
much, despite whatever they might want to believe,
they are quite similar in many ways. She's going
after gun bans. And Lauren Boebert said yesterday
that if you ban assault weapons, not even if
you ban all guns, if you ban assault weapons and
people still can have handguns, people are going
to end up eating dogs here in the United States.
What? Listen.
Speaker 2: Bring her live.
Speaker 1: Providing a crust for your.
Speaker 2: Employees, providing for your family.
Why did you do what you.
Speaker 1: Did.
Speaker 2: In a public forum in front of that
politician? Why did you feel the need to stand up?
Speaker 3: Yes. So, Dr. Gorka. My upbringing
I lived under failed policies. I lived in a
Democrat household. And I saw firsthand the.
Speaker 1: Policies of her own parents in that
Democrat household where her parents
distributed food to all the kids,
even though the kids weren't working. She was
living under democratic socialism in her own home.
Speaker 3: It's firsthand how restrictive their
policies are. There's not a lot of liberty
under Democrat rule, and in fact, that left us
in breadlines waiting for government cheese.
And I knew that that was not America's best.
Speaker 1: They give out cheese in the bread line.
Can you believe that? That sounds unorganized.
Speaker 3: 11 years old. So I started working as
a young teenager at a McDonald's and learned that
I could do a better job taking care of myself than
government did. Now, fast forward my I have a
husband, four wonderful boys and a restaurant
and a lot of employees, vendors, patrons.
Speaker 1: The restaurant has closed.
Speaker 3: That I needed to take care of. And
I saw the Second Amendment to be the best line
of defense to make sure everyone was kept safe
in my establishment. Now I am a petite woman,
and I need an equalizer. I need an equalizer to
protect me against a larger potential aggressor.
And when Beto O'Rourke told the world the
Democrat playbook. Hell, yes, we intend to
take your AR 15 and your AK 47. I was compelled to
go to him because I saw that a disarmed populace,
if the citizenry in America is disarmed, then
we are no longer citizens. We are subjects here
in America. We have gourmet treats for puppies.
We have these amazing groomers for dogs. Well,
in Venezuela, they eat the dogs. And it started
because they don't have firearms. They do not
have a way to protect themselves, to defend
themselves against a tyrannical government.
Speaker 1: Now, a great way to test this
hypothesis. No assault weapons leads to eating
dogs would be to look at the countries around
the world where you can't get assault weapons
and they're really not eating dogs in any
of those countries. Now, I know that there
are a few countries where dog meat is eaten, and
we've talked about some of those countries before.
And those countries have a sort of varying
gun legislation. But by and large, I looked
there is no correlation between dog eating and
bans on all weapons guns, never mind specifically
assault weapons. This is yet another one of these
scare tactics. They don't know what to do next.
It's but it's gotten to a point with the gun
stuff. Where the country is ready to say,
let's try doing something with the guns. Now, not
everybody and certainly not our elected officials.
But at this point, most people don't think the
issue is just mental health. Most people don't
think the issue is just doors or ladders or
staircases or fire escapes or whatever else.
At some point, many people are going to say,
I don't love it necessarily, but let's at
least try dealing with the guns. They may they
being Republicans, they may lose the midterms
because of their unwillingness to
do anything as far as the guns go.
And so now they're coming up with, you know,
if we ban the guns, you're going to be eating,
you're going to be eating. Sparky
Sparky's going to be barbecued
if we get rid of guns. And of course, it's absurd.
And they're desperate to prevent anything being
done about the guns. Now, will anything
be done about the guns? Remains to be seen